[Music]
thank you
Maui has a higher number of shark
attacks than any of the other Islands
State approached the shark lab to try to
figure out what was going on
why do we see this seasonal influx
so to help me solve this mystery I need
to deploy a camera accelerometer package
on a free swimming tiger shark
it involves me putting a clamp onto the
dorsal fin of the tiger shark while free
diving
[Music]
guys guys we have a shark on the line
she's on it she's on the base
oh my gosh Paige this is huge
Jules is trying to give us a signal
cage is going down
foreign
[Music]
place to me
it's like this little Oasis in the
middle of an ocean desert
animals here will test you just as much
as the ocean itself will
it requires you to be always on your
game
my name is Paige Burnley
I study tiger sharks at the Hawaii
Institute of Marine Biology shark
research lab
[Music]
I grew up in a super small town on a
lake where fishing was really my first
love
[Music]
I was in high school and I got to go on
my first fishing charter offshore
and I saw a Shark for the first time
I was so moved by it
so I moved out to Hawaii
you know I've spent my entire adult life
here pursuing shark research
and it has really shaped me into the
woman and the scientists that I am today
it's here at the shark research lab
Paige aims to solve a mystery that began
a decade ago on the island of Maui
unfortunately 10 years ago there was a
rash of tragic accidents involving tiger
sharks
the state approached the shark lab to
try to figure out what was going on
in order to get to the bottom of the
attacks Paige's PhD advisor Carl Meyer
began to tag and track tiger sharks
it's a big girl look at that
until we went to Maui and we captured 40
odd tiger sharks
and we equip them with different types
of transmitters that allow us to study
their movement patterns Carl went
forward with not only looking at the
Sharks on Maui but obviously comparing
them to the other Islands
the data revealed something astonishing
tiger sharks across Hawaii stick to
their home Islands most of the year
then during the winter they Converge on
Maui
it's not really typical behavior for
these animals to come together in high
numbers in one place like that
scientific Community was baffled
[Music]
in order to solve the mystery
levers were placed around Maui
they collected data every time a tagged
shark passed by and one receiver stood
out from all the rest
[Music]
when we recovered the receiver from
oluwalu that's when we started to see
this really interesting pattern during
the winter the concentration of sharks
off the coast of olive was off the
charts
Carl began to catch and fit sharks with
cameras to gather evidence
Lima there's the camera so I want the
camera on the outboard side
in 2015 he captured video from a male
tiger shark that almost solved the
mystery
now he shows the footage to Paige for
the first time so here you can see the
shark is actually swimming fairly
sedately over an area of coral reef and
then suddenly accelerates
you can see the reef going back and
forth back and forth back and forth
it starts Banking and turning and it's
swimming in these tight spirals as if
it's trying to catch up with something
that's turning away from me
there it is now there
the tagged male pursues a female in what
Carl thinks is an attempt to meet a
behavior never before observed with
tiger sharks and she's rolling her eyes
indicating that she doesn't want this
male to catch up with her she
outmaneuvered him and swam off
that is so close
we've got the movement patterns showing
the animals going there we've got
evidence that the sharks are mating but
what we don't have is any actual proof
direct proof Paige thinks she may be
able to get to the bottom of the mystery
with a new camera tagging technique
it involves me putting a clamp onto the
dorsal fin of the tiger shark while free
diving with the animal
scientists generally agree that shark
behavior is disrupted for about two days
after being caught on a line and tagged
so instead of bringing the shark to the
scientist
the scientist will go to the shop
this deployment method is minimally
impactful and minimally invasive and
will hopefully not deter them from
continuing on with their normal day if
it works any shark on the hunt for a
mate could capture footage of the event
immediately there's no guarantee of
success but if we're able to get a tiger
shark during mating season put a tag on
it with one of these camera tags then
there's a chance that we'll be able to
get the Smoking Gun evidence
first Paige needs to perfect her tagging
technique
and see if the Sharks return to their
natural behavior after the fact
to do this she'll start on her home turf
of Oahu where tiger sharks are more
habituated to humans than on Maui
interacting with sharks in the water
when you're just diving with them is one
thing but trying to quote unquote do
something to them changes the dynamic
completely
she needs an extra pair of hands and
eyes in the water
and there's one lab mate that fits the
bill one shark
two sharks three sharks at one
I need jewels
Jules hartle has been free diving with
sharks for almost a decade
she will act as Paige's safety diver
SE this is really Paige's project I'm
here for the Long Haul and I'm here to
help her as much as I can
today Paige's goal is to approach a
shark from its blind spot and attempt to
make contact
I have to get kind of right on top of
one of these in order to put the clamp
onto its dorsal fin
there's no knowing how it will react but
it is an essential step to prove that
non-invasive tagging can work
before long
hungry Galapagos sharks begin to Circle
one of Hawaii's most fearsome Predators
they can grow to about 10 feet long and
usually stay deep hunting in groups just
offshore
okay
but the scent of food has brought a
frenzy to the surface
Galapagos sharks are extremely
calculating in the water
we're seeing Galapagos sharks kind of
stack in numbers and they're kind of
starting to surround us a little bit
these are really powerful animals that
have the potential to be extremely
dangerous and cause a lot of damage
we're just kind of watching their
behavior counting their numbers
Paige hopes this exercise will help
develop skills needed for her ultimate
goal
to put a tag on a tiger shark by hand
but as she tries to make contact
the Galapagos shark swims off
the behavior of the group is changing
the sharks are skittish
then Paige sees why
a massive tiger
looking for an easy meal
the species that I need the most
practice with because this is the
species that I'm looking to put a tag on
there is no playbook for this
I'm literally kind of writing the book
with Jules
the shark doesn't react at all
[Music]
Step One is complete if Jules is with me
I know that I can safely work with these
sharks
the Gathering of tiger sharks in Maui
grows Closer by day
the team heads out for the next step
with the more habituated Oahu tigers
prove that it's possible to tag a tiger
shark while free diving
tagpage has is light years ahead of what
her Mentor Carl used in 2014.
we have a wheel here that gives me the
tiger shark speed through the water
the cameras here a gyroscope also
records the orientation of the shark in
the water
and a beacon provides its location
after a preset amount of time the tag
will fall off the shark and emit a radio
signal so Paige can retrieve it
this is the shark get your tag
it's a big female
where is she
going down
okay
Jules provide some incentive to stick
around
the first opportunity that I see I need
to just take advantage of it
the first approach startles the shark
all I'm thinking is this is it
foreign
I start kicking as hard as I can
she angles her body down just as I'm
putting the tag on
and I release my hand from the tag a
fraction of a second too early
and the tag pops off of her
and it just immediately starts sinking
it hurts a little but getting closer
the mistake will cost page valuable time
clamp is programmed to dissolve in salt
water so the tag will stay at the bottom
for 48 hours before floating to the
surface
two days later things get even worse
tags should be at the Surface by now
but Paige isn't picking up a signal
I am not hearing anything
not getting location information from a
tag usually means
that's it
it's the only tag she has
the entire Maui mission
could be sunk
oh my gosh I blew it
just as the team is about to give up
hope on finding the camera attack
Paige hears something
I hope I'm not like crazy
like
sure if I'm hearing something if I am
it's really fake
this way
turn into the wind more starboard
starboard
[Music]
I looked that way and I couldn't believe
that there was just big orange 11 000
tag sitting in the Blue Water this
little guy is what saved the day today
[Music]
I truly cannot believe I found that
that's crazy half of the game is just
having the tenacity to keep getting up
and trying again every time you get
knocked down
parts for Maui in less than three months
and successful tag deployment is still a
box unchecked
today while the rest of the team focuses
on tagging Galapagos sharks
Paige will be on the lookout for another
tiger
oh my God you're freaking ripped joining
the team is fellow scientists and shark
researcher Chloe blandina
watch your toes and assistant Madison
hold on
Carl
anything else don't look at me you guys
for the shots
the team hopes to deploy several
acoustic transmitters on the mission
an acoustic transmitter is a small
device that is implanted into a shark
and they can go about their whole rest
of their life without any bother and we
can then Trace their movements it's the
same technology used by Carl to track
tiger sharks in 2014.
[Music]
right off the bow easy easy
I'm kind of shark already
I can't say for certain that it's a
female but her body characteristic is
definitely feminine
in order to implant the transmitter they
need to do it the traditional way all
right fishing gears ready and catch the
shark we want to keep them interested
but not like too full
you right here Paige coming to you we've
got two sharks
so let's yeah yeah okay almost we're
here mama we just want to give you a
little work up
make sure you're okay
take some extra bling
yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
okay keep eyes on the buoy
all right Paige nice and easy
game
once the shark is on the hook we need to
be able to quickly restrain the animal
in a way that keeps the Animal Safe
all right okay I'm gonna pull her up
another free swimmer uh-oh uh oh
I like tiger
oh my gosh
while the arrival of the tiger could
benefit Paige at the moment the concern
is for the Galapagos shark on the line
the large tiger shark could make an easy
meal of it
right here give it some snacks give it
some snacks
we're gonna get this shark up so that
he's not dinner
no worry
we don't know its level of interest in
this Galapagos shark but we do know that
we need to get this job done and release
the animal okay
we work your magic Chloe there you go
over and under
oh
hey clean it
rolling the shark over calms the Frantic
Galapagos and puts her in what's called
tonic immobility
kind of like a natural sleep slash
comatose state for them
beautiful good job girls
it makes it even easier pickings for the
tiger shark
so um everyone keep an eye on a big
teeth we're looking for like an 11
footer
don't get this Galapagos
[Music]
I can't believe we got a tiger
tis the season the tiger appears
uninterested in the hooked Galapagos
shark so Jules proceeds quickly with the
surgery
okay knife please
there we go okay beautiful
thank you so it's ID number 9853
tag is in Needle please you're all right
relax you
all right perfect bag is in suture is
done we're gonna flip this animal over
I'm gonna live a long and healthy life
yes baby
go get them
no yes girl
yeah we're just gonna keep chumming I
think and Tee It Up
now Paige has another chance to tag in
Oahu tiger shark before they gather in
moment as soon as I jumped in while
she's prepping the camera Paige this is
your shot this is your shard
foreign
I am really trying to just let the rest
of the noise that's going on in my head
kind of fade away
and I am on a level of focus that I have
not experienced before in my life
I looked over and she's already swimming
down
she's literally like at that one point
right behind the shark where he can't
quite see the back of his dorsal fin
my heartbeat in that moment was so loud
in my ears it was like I couldn't hear
anything else
and seeing it go on right where it needs
to be the shark had no idea until Boom
the clamp went on
and I was just so relieved like I was
just like yeah so I was like we did it
we didn't know what the shark was gonna
do after the tag was put on his dorsal
fin
[Music]
and then he comes back
Here Comes This tiger shark with a
bright orange little package and we were
just like ah now we're on his camera you
know it's so cool now the shark's
filming us
[Music]
page this is the culmination of years of
preparation
[Music]
the sense of relief that I felt once I
saw that the camera was on was it was
huge
[Music]
super proud of her
she has worked her butt off for the last
few years to make sure that this thing
is deployed on a tiger shark and she
nailed it
[Music]
Paige has proven that it doesn't disturb
the shark's natural behavior in the
slightest
I mean the fact that he came back around
validates the method of tagging
it was exciting enough to see from the
shark's point of view but then I see
that he actually went and swam up to
another tiger shark
which is just insane as it brings the
proof of concept full circle
a uniquely skilled team
trained in the right way with the right
equipment and we have that team
I have no doubt that Paige has the
ability to pull this off
[Music]
by January the shark migration is in
full swing
Olo value should be swarming with sharks
from around Hawaii
so this is the site that I'm really
interested in looking at for a tiger
shark mating aggregation
this is where I have the best chance of
getting a tag on
I need to start here
all right what have we got
all right we've got some nice Mahi
carcasses today
I know exactly what to expect from these
Maui tiger sharks
the tiger sharks on Maui I expect to be
a little bit more wild mating can be
very dangerous for female tiger sharks
so I expect them to be very cautious and
I kind of expect the opposite from the
males more unpredictability jumpy it's
just going to be a completely different
game than it was on Oahu
let us know if you need more pieces of
jump page and Jules will have Kaylee
another shark lab researcher to help
them on mold showing one hand notes in
the other it isn't long before they're
Captain Corey she's the first visitor of
the day
guys guys we got a tiger shark in the
water over here
it's a good omen for the mission
you ready
the Maui tiger shark is wary of jewels
obviously a little shy
let's send the crate down deep again and
then pull it up really slowly
we're really just trying to entice her
to come in a Little Closer
does anyone have eyes on her that's a
negative
it's nothing like the Oahu sharks
I haven't seen the tiger shark approach
our area even in five to ten minutes
the Drone will give Corey a better View
foreign
[Applause]
guys we have a second tiger shark coming
in
that's enough for Paige
having multiple tiger sharks around the
boat was really exciting but then as
soon as we get in the water
they exhibit that really really shy
Behavior
[Music]
not people friendly she's like yeah no
swim away please thanks
and the tiger shark is gone
this is catastrophic for the project
this as it stands right now if it
doesn't change is game over
the next morning it's more of the same
the tiger sharks are not giving page and
Jules the time of day
they're potentially looking for a mate
and then there's little us with our
cooler trying to make ourselves as
attractive as possible
mating very well could be what's keeping
the tiger sharks at a distance
as the days go along
it comes apparent that there may be a
much bigger distraction here
yeah baby
oh
that scared me
[Music]
each winter humpback whales descend on
Maui by the thousands
every time I turn around there's one
breaching
they've come from the North Pacific to
mate give birth and raise their young in
the warm Waters of Hawaii tiger sharks
are migrating to this area during
mid-winter yes we think for mating
or are they coming to Maui to take
advantage of humpback whale season
if there's a chance that Maui's humpback
whales play a role in this tiger shark
mystery Paige needs to get to the bottom
of it
she knows just the man to talk to
the hell over the rail
Ed Lyman has been working with Hawaiian
humpbacks for 20 years
often coming to the rescue of Wales
Tangled in fishing lines
Paige hopes he can provide some insight
into how their arrival affects the tiger
shark population
is there any kind of interactions that
you see between tiger sharks and
humpback whales and if so kind of what
do those look like there's been times
where we've had compromised animals and
it has drawn sharks sharks have shown up
and we've actually seen the animals
basically kill the whale
they're a good example page would be
carcasses it food for them
tiger sharks that typically inhabit Oahu
coastlines or Big Island coastlines will
actually migrate to Maui during these
midwinter months it makes some sense
based again on what we know of the whale
movement patterns their concentrations
the number of calves that are born here
because we know they don't all make it I
mean some older dad I suggest that one
in five are not going to make it oh wow
humpback whale blubber muscle visceral
tissue all of that is very very calorie
dense
the massive influx of potential food
could be a large part of why the Maui
sharks are not hanging around for scraps
of fish
one thing we can do is we're getting
calls on compromised animals especially
in Tango whales some of those we know
are not going to make it
we'll let your team know that there's a
potential case where sharks might be
looking for a meal yeah that would be
amazing
Paige is running out of time
points all over Hawaii
and the Mystery of what they do here
each winter is no closer to being solved
we are
shark around the boat every
tiger at the surface right here right
here right here but we're playing by
their rules
it's like as soon as you give up is when
they show up is like the running trend
of this trip just like don't stop we're
here don't forget we're we'll come
around it's like okay well we've just
been out here for like 36 hours
my window is slowly closing and maybe I
can get something done but not with the
way things are right now
time runs out on their Maui Expedition
Paige gets a call from Ed Lyman the
whale expert
there's an injured humpback a few miles
away the sharks have taken a couple
bites out of it already I'm not sure if
it's still alive or if it's kind of let
go
best lead yet
when they arrive the whale is clinging
to life
a second humpback circles
watching helplessly as several tiger
sharks line up to feast
holy really fired up just from the
prospect of this whale that's going to
die soon
before long an eight-foot male the
smallest of the group breaks away to
check out the boat
[Music]
that's a beautiful animal that's like
exactly what I'm looking for
for a shark at the bottom of the pecking
order the promise of a guaranteed meal
is too much to resist
open up
I'm gonna go get in and say hi
the shark circles page dropping its
pectoral fins and rolling its eyes
a clear sign her presence is viewed as a
threat
his energy levels are very elevated he's
coming in really hard making these sharp
fast turns then it goes for the boat
he's like you are now other things in
the water that are big I'm competing
with you as well you need to get out of
this space
Paige calls off the dive
this is not a safe situation for me to
try and do a deployment and it's really
unfortunate because I don't know if I'll
ever get another opportunity like this
or another interaction like this with
sharks on a whale
the team is running out of hope that
they will get a tag on a shark this
season
with the lore of humpbacks the team
upgrades their bait from mahi mahi to
ahi tuna
only thing we can do is wait and just
keep chumming
right now we've got a bakery down at
depth and then we've got a float line
where the carcass hanging off of it so
we're kind of all guns blazing right now
[Music]
oh I gotta get my suit
she's on it she's on the bait
dude
coming at us slowly slowly
it appears the bait change is just what
they needed
the female checks out the bait keeping
an eye on the mail
it could be he's interested in her as a
possible mate
but the female over matches him in size
and confidence
ranks on the food
the male swims on
coming right under you
Jules keeps the female's attention
while Paige sizes her up
as soon as I got in the water I could
tell she was cautious but comfortable
enough to make close passes to me which
is really what I had been looking for
the entire time
I see her she's coming back to the bow
the 11 foot female is the most
interactive shark they have encountered
in Maui
the shark circles at 25 feet below the
surface interested in The Bait Box
it's too deep
Jules needs to lure it closer to the
surface
cage is going down
perfect moment I get a close pass from
this female it's honestly perfect she's
moving very slowly just kind of right
underneath me
I got it on my camera
is approaching the shark
I was kind of hanging back a little bit
just trying to be ready for any kind of
reaction
I just get like booted
and it starts sinking
startled shark beats its powerful tail
to get away and hits Paige hard
sending the tag flying
it's a wild tiger shark so they're fully
capable of telling us no Paige just
ended up right in the line of fire the
shark hit page with what is called the
peduncle
the end of the shark's muscle body just
forward of the fleshy tail
it's like getting hit with a baseball
bat
that's a really hard hit and it's gotta
hurt the clamp was over the dorsal fin
and the movement of the fin itself
actually popped the tag off
[Music]
Jules grabs the tag just in time
but Paige is shaking are you okay I
think I need to sit for a minute
take a deep breath you got it
I don't know dude he's gone my arm hurts
pretty bad
I can only imagine what Paige is feeling
it definitely rattles you
Dives again there's a chance she might
not be able to secure the tag properly
jewels just give it a shot
Paige makes the tough call for Jules to
take them across the finish line
it was literally like the last 10
minutes of daylight that we're trying to
work with and I'm like just go if you
see an opportunity just get after it
Jules has the tag she's committed to the
deployment at this point I'm right there
next to her
I know that's a lot coming from her to
put that responsibility in my hands but
we're a team
[Music]
she's on the bait let's go let's go
I look at Jules and she's already diving
down just taking advantage of that
opportunity of having the shark
distracted and right in our space
and she goes down and she just Nails it
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so proud of Jules for being able to
pull it off it's been so grueling and so
many ups and downs of trying to get this
done in this area so to finally see a
package on a tiger shark in Maui
and watch it swim away I mean it's just
so cool
yeah I couldn't ask for anything more
[Music]
Paige bornley and her team have made
history
they successfully deployed a camera tag
on a free swimming tiger shark in Maui
for the first time
proves that we can free dive with these
tiger sharks on Maui we can get
successful deployments we can get
footage back we can get interactions
with other tiger sharks two o'clock I
see it
it means the mystery of what's bringing
the tiger sharks here is one step closer
to being solved got it
we deployed on a female but we see two
other males in the footage kind of in
that inshore habitat with her sharing
the same space it's a breakthrough to
the mystery that can't be overlooked
male tiger sharks are typically found in
more offshore habitats and so it's not
the usual thing to see males close in to
Coastal habitats it's amazing we can see
a female being pursued by two males it
makes the puzzle that much more exciting
what we've seen so far is really just
the tip of the iceberg
no The Works the work's not done we're
really just getting started
there's never a time that I ever doubted
that she could do anything and I think
that now she is completely Unstoppable
so proud proud of the effort that the
whole team has put in really to
accomplish this it's not something that
I could ever attempt to do by myself
we have a lot of hard-working people a
lot of love and we have a kick-ass team
of women out here and we're making it
happen
[Music]